[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANIK DAHR: So
Beyond the Road event
is a series of events
in different locations
around the world.
What we do is we go to each
of these important cities
and present Google Maps
to the enterprise world.
So a lot of companies
nowadays are using Google Maps
for different use cases.
GABRIEL CARVALHO:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
HELENA KALE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
NERIDA BERNAL:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
STEPHANIE WU: The
world is becoming
increasingly connected.
Everyone has a mobile
device, and so location is
really, really important now.
And so leveraging these APIs,
what's really unique about them
is that we give
businesses the power
to build their own solutions.
Most people think about Maps
as just, like, a visual.
We're more beyond
the map, actually.
We're trying to
encourage companies
to think beyond
visualization and just think
about location intelligence.
OCTAVIO DEL CONDE:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
LORENA BRACHO:
OCTAVIO DEL CONDE:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
LORENA BRACHO:
GABRIEL LEON: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
MANIK DAHR: The
Mexican consumers,
the Mexican
businesses can really
leverage Google
mapping technology
and make it better
for themselves.
[MUSIC PLAYING]